hi everyone I guess I'm miked up I can
stand right here I'm just here to
introduce our next speaker who's one of
my just favorite people Diane Greene she
is you all I'm sure know her so she
needs no introduction but she's the
chief of Google's cloud businesses and
prior to that amongst many of the things
she did she was the founder and CEO of
VMware so she's gonna come out say a few
words then I'm gonna come out and join
her and do some Q&A for her talk so
welcome Diane hi I was trying to figure
out what to do because I like to read my
notes and the electrum was too high for
my five-foot-one self so you know it's
just such a total pleasure for me to be
here you know more than 800 female
founders from all over the world some of
you just public yeah yeah so some of you
probably starting your careers and many
of you in the early stages of your
developing your companies and I think
it's just like incredibly exciting you
know there's so much possibility sitting
in this room this one auditorium and
imagine all the interesting challenges
that you're going to surmount and all
that's gonna be what you're going to be
required to navigate so a little bit
about myself I'd been a co-founder and
CEO of three startups and the first was
the extreme in 1995 where we developed a
low bandwidth streaming video technology
we could stream sort of postage sized
videos across the internet and we sold
this to Microsoft in 1997 for 75 million
and that became the basis of Microsoft's
movie player' my second startup was
VMware and we launched with that we
launched the virtualization revolution
and that we don't we've founded that in
1998 and we took it public in 2007 and
the market kept closed that day at 19
point 1 billion dollars so my last start
up to date was bebop which we founded in
2013 and then we sold it to Google in
2015 for 380 million and I committed my
portion of the proceeds to a nonprofits
through a donor advised fund okay thank
you okay so before these start I don't
usually get so much applause here great
audience before these startups I I built
inside of larger companies at Sybase the
first tech company I worked at before
that I was a naval architect I developed
a synchronous input/output software to
make the database run faster and
actually we were able to be Oracle and
ingress and all the other database
companies at the benchmarks and and yeah
it was cool and and then I went to
tandem they actually fired my boss who
was a woman and she went to it was a
mistake she was running engineering and
I went to tandem with her and anyhow
there I helped create a hybrid
architecture to run an open UNIX based
world tandem had the best transaction
processing system in the world but it
was proprietary and then at SGI I
developed streaming video solutions and
that was part of the Time Warner
interactive television project which was
actually a precursor to the world wide
web and a lot of people in that group
went out Netscape was one of the
companies a lot of company started out
of that and then as a tech investor I've
advised and put seed money into a lot of
star
and they include two companies that are
now public Cloudera and pure storage and
also Unity Technologies which is the
gaming developer platform and several
others unfortunately my schedules now
such that I'd no longer have the time to
provide C money or or advice to startups
but anyhow I've learned a lot of lessons
along the way and I'm gonna now look
back and attempt to identify and share
them with you my first lessons were at a
very young age my mother was the latest
in a pretty strong principled Midwestern
schoolteacher lineage and my father was
a brilliant hard driving engineer an
entrepreneur and I was the second
youngest in my family a little girl in a
crowd are very competitive and
dominating brothers and we lived on a
creek that fed into the Chesapeake Bay
and my father conveyed his love of the
water to me and I soon found myself
taking off on long sails in my little
sailing dinghy and this was formative I
had suddenly you know was the mistress
of my world and in charge of a boat and
on my own you know facing overcoming the
challenges that the sea would present to
me and later on I would race bigger
boats and windsurfers I won the Women's
National dinghy sailing Championships I
raced long distance to Bermuda and and
down both of America's coasts and I win
surfed across open ocean from Maui to
Molokai and back
it's actually an amazing story but I'm
not going to go into it but but more
than anything I think my connection to
the sea has really helped me develop my
independence and a sense of importance
and value of my own vision and to sail
successfully you need to observe with
great care you need to identify with the
wind and the water are telling you and
then find a way to execute to reach
whatever goal you set be it simply
making it home to port or winning a race
building a company is so much like
racing a sailboat you need a plan and
then the ability to reevaluate the plan
in real time as new information is
acquired suddenly the wind changes or a
competitor is stronger than you thought
they'd be and each mark in the race is a
milestone where you need to look up and
evaluate what you're doing how you're
doing
and so when you campaign a sailboat you
need to be in the moment you need to let
go of your self-doubt and yet you can't
lose the ability to question your
decisions
so most of all when it's time to make a
decision
a competitors come upon you or the wind
shifted you make it the race won't wait
for you and finally when you race a
sailboat the selection of your crew is
just completely paramount it's
impossible to be an effective skipper if
you don't have the right people working
harmoniously and the right roles so what
does all this mean in terms when
founding or running a company at the
extreme I learned that the founders need
to be solidly aligned and that a
start-up maybe has a better chance of
success when the number of founders is
limited too many cooks can spoil the
broth most of all I learned that no one
is indispensable and it's essential to
get the right mix of people talents and
personalities VMware was really the
beginning of the end of an industry
revolution and from that I learned what
it takes to induce the market to accept
a profound
innovation is accentual to design a
market a major innovation in a way that
makes its adoption non-disruptive that
makes it easy to integrate with an
established order an established way of
doing things
even if the innovation ultimately
supplants that order so for example one
of the things that made our sales take
off you know we had this virtualization
layer but we we wouldn't build a tool
that would take a fit a workload running
in a physical machine and just magically
put it in a virtual machine and
everything just ran the same and that
was a phenomenal sales tool for us at
VMware I also was reminded not to let
step back to make you stop thinking if a
puzzle can't be solved one way there's
always another it's just a matter of
navigation we were really disappointed
when we learned that VMware would not be
able to sell through IB IBM due to IP
issues but then we turned it into an
advantage where we were able to work
with IBM to enlist all of their star
resellers to take us to market finally
at VMware I learned how essential it is
to create the right corporate culture we
worked hard to foster a sense of the
importance of each and every person and
the importance of each and every person
and also what their role was in the
furtherance of the company's objectives
and to create an open culture that would
make it easy for people to communicate
collaborate and share ideas and indeed
we designed our corporate campus with
exactly these goals in mind if any of
you've ever been to VMware and then
Beebop also provided an interesting set
of lessons I think it may be my last
startup but you really learn every time
my original co-founder didn't stay with
the company and I was at first sort of a
bit out of my element we were attempting
to reevaluate
and more effective in obtaining their
objectives but the basic look and feel
the design of our first attempts was
just off and we persevered and bebop
became a powerhouse for a design
thinking and for tools to build
enterprise applications tenacious knaves
off and now finally as head of Google
Cloud I'm learning that it's possible to
build an enterprise startup inside a
mega company once again the cultures of
both the parent and the in-house startup
are crucial and we're pretty big startup
we served seven apps that have over a
billion active users any out we're big
but and once again it is all about
having the right people and the right
roles and finally it's about never
taking your eye off creating value for
customers and partners so the bottom
line when sailing a boat or building a
company is that you give it your all you
give it your all not because you're
supposed to not because that's what
makes you makes you win but because you
have respect for your goal and you enjoy
the process as a company founder enjoy
building things you enjoy creating value
and the commitment that comes from
loving what you do is what will nourish
you it will satisfy you and I'll make
you unafraid of failure you may lose
this race or that one
but sailing ahead with everything you
you have will still be a pleasure you
may make a fortune but the fortune will
be incidental if your goals are worthy
it's the process that will count and
that understanding will be your greatest
source of strength no matter what the
adversity so thank you and now jessica
is going to come out and ask me
questions
Oh
you